[Applaudissements]
c'est l'un des terreaux les plus
fertiles pour le parti conservateur
mais en alberta une autre formation
politique séduit de plus en plus
d'électeurs de droite
les électeurs comme craig mostar qui
votent et bleu dans le passé mais qui ne
se retrouvent plus dans partie des
renault tout
maxime bernier cette fois-ci petit gars
de la beauce qui est devenue le
porte-voix des non vaccinés et des
opposants aux mesures sanitaires je
pense que cette élection là va être
référendum sur le passeport vaccinale si
aucun défaut bouffer d'accès que maxime
bernier est le seul à parler en leur nom
en soi ce n'est pas nécessairement très
surprenant
cette analyse de sondage le note depuis
le début de la campagne les intentions
de vote du parti populaire sont passés
de 2 3% à 6 7%
une montée légère mais qui pourrait
faire mal aux conservateurs surtout là
où ils se livrent une chaude lutte avec
les libéraux ça pourrait peut-être faire
basculer quelques sièges plus serré les
services urbains particulièrement on
parle de winnipeg calgary
où les conservateurs devraient gagner
théoriquement mais avec cette division
du vote peut-être que ça va être plus
serré que l'on croit et c'est perrine
o'toole ne se montre nullement préoccupé
non parce que je suis le seul chef qui
peuvent remplacer justin trudeau les
chefs libéral qui s'est élancé un nombre
incalculable d'insultés et même du
gravier par des militants du parti
populaire 5e malheureusement on voit que
le canada n'est pas à l'abri des mêmes
mouvement populiste extrémiste
intolérant le parti populaire pourrait
jouer les trouble-fête pour les
conservateurs dans certaines
circonscriptions au pays mais ce n'est
même pas sûr que la formation
réussissent à faire élire un seul député
aux communes le siège le plus prenable
et celui où je présente maxime bernier
en beauce mais c'est aussi au québec où
son parti le moins populaire et si
laurence martin radio canada vancouver